[Music]
across the whole planet humans eat on
average between 1 and 2.7 kilograms of
food a day
that's over 365 kilograms a year per
person and more than 28,000 800
kilograms over the course of a lifetime
and every last scrap makes its way
through the digestive system comprised
of ten organs covering nine meters and
containing over 20 specialized cell
types this is one of the most diverse
and complicated systems in the human
body its parts continuously work in
unison to fulfill a singular task
transforming the raw materials of your
food into the nutrients and energy that
keep you alive spanning the entire
length of your torso the digestive
system has four main components first
there's the gastrointestinal tract a
twisting channel that transports your
food and has an internal surface area of
between 30 and 40 square meters enough
to cover half a badminton court second
there's the pancreas gallbladder and
liver a trio of organs that break down
food using an array of special juices
third the body's enzymes hormones nerves
and blood all work together to break
down food modulate the digestive process
and deliver its final products finally
there's the mesentery a large stretch of
tissue that supports and positions all
your digestive organs in the abdomen
enabling them to do their jobs
the digestive process begins before food
even hits your tongue anticipating a
tasty morsel glands in your mouth start
to pump out saliva we produce about 1.5
liters of this liquid each day once
inside your mouth chewing combines with
the sloshing saliva to turn food into a
moist lump called the bolus enzymes
present in the saliva break down any
starch then your food finds itself at
the rim of a 25 centimeter long tube
called the esophagus down which it must
plunge to reach the stomach
nerves in the surrounding esophageal
tissue since the bolus presence and
trigger peristalsis a series of defined
muscular contractions that propels the
food into the stomach where it's left at
the mercy of the muscular stomach walls
which pound the bolus breaking it into
chunks hormones secreted by cells in the
lining trigger the release of acids and
enzyme rich juices from the stomach wall
that start to dissolve the food and
break down its proteins these hormones
also alert the pancreas liver and
gallbladder to produce digestive juices
and transfer bile a yellowish green
liquid that digests fat in preparation
for the next stage after three hours
inside the stomach the once Shapley
bolus is now a frothy liquid called
chyme and it's ready to move into the
small intestine the liver sends bile to
the gall bladder which secretes it into
the first portion of the small intestine
called the duodenum here it dissolves
the fats floating in the slurry of chyme
so they can be easily digested by the
pancreatic and intestinal juices that
have leached onto the scene these enzyme
rich juices break the fat molecules down
into fatty acids and glycerol for easier
absorption into the body the enzymes
also carry out the final deconstruction
of proteins into amino acids and
carbohydrates into glucose this happens
in the small intestines lower regions
the jejunum and ileum which are coated
in millions of tiny projections called
villi these create a huge surface area
to maximize molecule absorption and
transference into the bloodstream the
blood takes them on the final leg of
their journey to feed the body's organs
and tissues but it's not over quite yet
leftover fiber water and dead cells
slough off during digestion make it into
the large intestine also known as the
colon the body drains out most of the
remaining fluid through the intestinal
wall what's left is a soft mass called
stool the colon squeezes this by-product
into a pouch called the rectum where
nerves sense it expanding and tell the
body when it's time
to expel the waste the byproducts of
digestion exit through the anus and the
food's long journey typically lasting
between 30 and 40 hours is finally
complete ted-ed is a nonprofit if you
value our work please consider
supporting it on patreon.com slash
ted-ed
[Music]